Hey, good morning everybody.
Sorry about that. I'm running over, uh, this meeting
with one of my, uh, partners, Karthik,
and they're trying to understand, uh, what, what,
how in the world are we doing email like we are.
Everybody in the business is trying to understand
what we're doing 'cause they don't understand it.
And the way he approached me today is said, man,
every single time you come in a promo,
nobody's heard from you, and then you smash everybody.
How are you doing this? So I
walked in, like through the email.
I walked in, through gc, nothing like that exists.
And when I helped 'em understand,
and I want you guys to understand this,
we're gonna dive into it today, is, uh,
autoresponders are a scam.
Is there anybody that's figured this out yet?
Who has figured out that autoresponders are a scam?
Now, obviously, everything's ROI if you make more money than
you're spending, um, okay, fair enough.
And, and that's the, uh, what'd you put on my shirt? Doggie.
That is the, um, um, position I've always been in
with autoresponders.
You know, I don't, I'm not a guy that mails a lot.
So there's some months
where I would spend more than on an autoresponder than I was
making, which is a big no-no.
Um, but yeah, I, I told 'em autoresponders are a scam.
And the reason why is
because they charge you based on number of contacts.
But I promise you, 80%
of your contacts could care less about what you're doing.
And so what you need to do is focus on the 20% that matter.
Does that make sense to you guys?
Is everybody starting to understand this?
So, no other system that I know of tells you flat out
what the 20% is.
Now, we've gotten so good at what we're doing.
We've gotten so good at hot listing.
We've gotten so good at figuring out, um,
like right now I'm sending out some videos on some
of this stuff we're doing with Open Clock,
and I'm tagging them as people
that are interested in Open Claw.
Would you believe that? I have over a thousand people.
Usually I get about three to 500.
I got over a thousand people
that are saying I'm interested in Open Claw just from
sending out a simple bridge page that Open Claw built,
by the way, right?
So it's, it's pretty extraordinary.
And, uh, now they're trying to understand this
and they're trying to understand what we figured out.
Well, today, uh, it's going the other way.
Now, now, and it is the same thing for Nick's company too.
Nick has 3000 clickers. He canceled everything.
He canceled active campaign,
he canceled Ontraport, he canceled everything.
He had three different autoresponder.
He said, dude, I'm canceling 'em all.
I understand what you built with your system.
We have 3000 clickers in his account, right?
So, and, and I'm, I'm not up to 3000 clickers.
I'm up to like 2,500.
So I told the team today, I said, Hey,
uh, we gotta change this.
Now, when you select activity,
before I was mailing the openers, which, you know,
was like 3000 openers.
Now I'm over 12, 10,000 openers.
So now I need the ability just to mail the clickers, right?
So it is getting really, really interesting
with the email stuff, right?
Really interesting with the email stuff, right?
So, uh, the reason why I bring all that up is
'cause yes, I was on a call with Karthik
and he's, we're getting him all set up
with his email stuff today.
There's no doubt in my mind he will cancel autoresponders
after what we set up.
So the same thing that we do for newsletters
and everything else, uh, we're getting him set up with his,
uh, all of his DNS, right?
The SPF, the DKM, the DA, right?
We're gonna warm it up first 50 today,
then tomorrow, a hundred an hour.
Then the next day, 200 an hour. Same thing we did with Nick.
Same thing we did with everybody.
And then I'm trying to convince him to, uh,
create some trainings or whatever
and put 'em inside of course route
so we can warm people up that way, right?
Well, now, uh, now Open Claw will do all that for us.
Now, I have a confession to make,
and I'll show you this on the screen here in a minute.
I was so sick this weekend,
and for some reason, now I've hurt my back on top of that.
I don't know where that came from.
I did zero in open claw zero.
Now, I kept hearing ping, ping, ping, ping, ping.
Um, and, uh, I was showing Friday.
I was showing Connie Friday night how it would go and,
and, uh, write an article for her, uh,
because she's so busy.
She's had freaking 30 consultations in the last week alone
from a simple little ad
that we're out there running for her.
Um, and, and,
and she's so busy doing that,
that I don't want the newsletter to slip away.
So I was showing her,
and I was, I mean, I was kind of cranky Friday night.
I was tired. It was a long week long productive week.
Um, and it was asking me some questions
and I was answering wrong or whatever,
and I finally just threw my phone down
and it knew I was frustrated.
So I woke up to a message, um, uh, last night,
I think at 11 o'clock at night,
and I'll show you what it did.
It knew I was frustrated.
And so it went and, um, found a solution for me.
I'm gonna show that to you guys. So you understand,
because my open Claw has permission
to start thinking like a CEO.
I gave it that permission, right?
Um, but I did nothing this weekend. Nothing.
Uh, it woke up and said, Hey,
you got your newsletter call here this morning.
What are your bullet points?
And I'm like, no, we're gonna do this
open cloth thing instead.
Newsletter call will continue next week.
So it's on track, it's scheduled out.
Um, but I did nothing all weekend, right?
So, uh, I don't, I don't have any big revelations.
Um, today on the call, we're gonna dive into the GC.
API GC is really important
because that's where our contacts are.
So now we can pull up, uh, contact details.
Uh, that's where our tags are.
So now we can, uh, fire off tags,
we can set up integrations on top of that.
Yes, we can write emails.
We can tell it to write an email
and mail it out to a certain tag.
Now it's gonna get even better
because they're gonna set it up to
where we can now mail just the clickers,
which I'm super, super excited about.
'cause now if I just mail the clickers,
I am gonna have the highest open rate
and even the highest click through rate just
by mailing the clickers, right?
And that's gonna help me reduce my cost, right?
Um, also, uh, I want you guys to sign up
for a new API key today.
Uh, we're gonna give you the command to get it installed.
Uh, we have been playing with it, um, pretty happy with the,
uh, response, especially when things are trained.
Um, it's gonna reduce your token cost by about 85%.
Um, the other thing is, I want you guys to know
that we are also looking into something called token
caching, which is also going to reduce, uh, by a lot.
Okay? Um, so we'll probably cover, um, that tomorrow.
Um, but the, is there anybody that has a QE 2.5, uh,
API, anybody at all?
Does it? Or does anybody have that, um,
that model whatsoever?
Gimme 2.5.
Um, let me see if I can get you guys a link
and I will share that with you.
Hold on a second. Let me, uh, let me grab this real quick.
And, uh, on Friday, Friday was a pretty good call
because we went
and created our, uh, well, let me check in with you guys.
How many of you, um, connected your, uh, who,
who went out there and got a GitHub account
and who connected it to cel?
Did anybody do that? And no, I have not been able
to shoot those videos yet.
I'm sorry. I'm hoping I can shoot 'em tomorrow.
And just so you guys know, I'm supposed to be in Florida.
Um, this week I'm supposed to be speaking at an event.
I'm supposed to be, uh, attending an AD Mastermind.
I, I can't do anything. I can't do anything.
I'll be here all week. Um, so Braa did,
I couldn't open Claws down since Friday night.
If your open claws down, put your hand up, put your hand up,
G and Perneel reach out to you on the side, uh,
they will get it fixed, most likely.
You probably seem to do a gateway restart,
but, um, raise your hand.
And, uh, if you could help, uh,
Steve Pne, I'd appreciate it.
Um, so let me open this guy up. Copy link.
Okay. So let's see. Here we go.
All right. And I want the, uh,
English version of this.
Hold on English, okay?
Um, so let me put this link in the chat.
You are gonna want the English version, okay?
Wasn't live on Friday,
but watched Replay, got Versal, got Camba working on there,
got Claw to give me a pop link for it.
Good, good deal. Yeah.
So, um, for your information, Brian Anderson's call.
Uh, okay, I'm gonna be on that call, Chris, thank you.
I gotta follow up with him. Anyways, um, this, uh,
moonshot, uh, it is a, uh,
Chinese platform.
Um, a lot of people are very, very happy with it.
Uh, when you install perplexity,
it is one of the options there.
So Perplexity is backing them, right?
Um, I don't know how I feel about
that stuff when it comes to sensitive data.
I certainly wouldn't want it to have
my credit cards or anything.
Um, but for what we're doing with, uh, the titanium,
you know, APIs and everything, I'm, I'm fine with it.
Like, if I can reduce my cost by 85%, I'm gonna do that.
Um, guys, the thing that's, uh, I I need you guys
to understand is, uh,
when I say we've spent a lot of money, I want you guys
to understand with the workshop happening,
with the training happening, um, we have, I think, four
or five different installs that are using the same API keys,
we haven't even spent, yeah, convert it to English.
Glenna, we haven't even spent a thousand dollars.
All the training, everything we've done,
we haven't even spent a thousand dollars.
And for a while, I was going every weekend, day and night.
Um, and, uh, even when I went to bed, the, the night team,
when they were building out the APIs for Min Burn
and everything, uh, they were testing it.
They, they were in there, you know,
testing the APIs back and forth, back and forth.
So yeah, that's gonna be a lot of money
for some people, okay?
For me, it's worth it
because just, um, ah, man, I, I was telling, uh, uh,
Karthik had me meeting with a very big influencer in India
this morning, and he was asking me to explain
what we figured out with this.
Just the fact that I know every single replay can go
up with a goal.
Um, oh, I'm sorry, I gave you the Chinese version.
Just the fact, listen to G don't listen to me.
Just the fact that every single replay, did you guys happen
to notice that there was a goal on the last replay?
Do you guys see that? There's, there's a goal block,
there's the replay.
So just the fact that every single replay now goes up
in a timely fashion,
and there's a goal block there
that's gonna bring in the comments, just the fact that, uh,
the Zoom webinars are automatically updated.
Just the fact that I can be at Disneyland,
I can take out my phone and say, Hey, do me a favor.
Make sure you write an email for this promo we're doing.
And it'll do all that, you know, send all that out.
Uh, just the fact that I can fire off a tag on the spot,
just a stuff that I've taught you guys
that I can do in, in my business
and what we're doing here was worth it.
You guys understand that it was worth spending a thousand
dollars, but now combine it with all the training
that we've done here and the back and forth
and everything else, it was totally worth it.
Now, the good news is this, we're just turning around
and handing you those zip files.
Is there anybody that's been installing those zip
files as we give 'em to you?
We've given you one for Letterman, we've given you one for,
um, uh, uh, whatchamacallit.
Which one for course route the other day,
or built the full courses?
Have you guys been installing those files?
When we give them to you time in the chat, let me know.
What I'm gonna do is I'm going to add those files, uh,
to the course route area, right?
So look, you want to be doing that.
Now, when you do that, for instance, if you,
if you're not using Vimeo, and you go
and install the, um, uh, the course sprout, uh, skill
that we did, right?
Well, there's parts of the skills
that are trained on looking for Vimeo.
So once you install it, you need to say, Hey, uh,
by the way, I don't use Vimeo.
What's the name of that one
other platform that you guys like?
It's got a weird name. There's two of 'em.
One of those other two platforms you guys are
always mentioning all the time.
We integrated all our software with it. What is it?
Uh, gum lit. Gum lit, not Loom. What's the other one?
Gum lit. And there's one other one. A So here's my question.
Does gum lit and alo, does it have API keys?
Does it have API keys?
And, uh, I'll come over here. Okay, ALO does.
So here's what you can do. When you install that zip file,
you say to open claw, Hey, um,
I know you're trained on Vimeo.
I don't wanna use Vimeo.
I would like to have the same exact process,
but I use a dello instead.
Here's my API key.
It'll go through, it'll do a dry run.
It'll say, okay, you know what? I found
the folder in a dello.
If a dillo uses folders, I, I don't know how it's set up.
Uh, I found, um,
and by the way, G, can you give em
the zip files here in the chat?
We'll get you taken care of. John, let's hop on a call too.
John, I want to, I want to connect with you.
Um, but, but you say, here's the api.
So we'll go through and do a dry run.
Say, okay, I found the folder. Boom, here's the video.
Oh, here's where a dlo does the transcribe.
All right, I transcribed it. Right?
So what we have to find out is when you give it the API key
for a dillo, ask it what its abilities are now.
So if I were to do this, I know nothing about a dillo,
but if I were to come over here, uh, let me go ahead
and, um, do this real quick.
I'll, I'll kind of run through this
with you guys real fast, just for a minute.
Um, share, share screen.
Okay, so I'm over here inside of, uh, perplexity. Yeah.
Does a dillo have an API key?
All right, so I'm gonna ask perplexity this.
And remember, I keep telling you
with perplexity, you could do sonar.
Gemini three. Gemini three pro GPT 5.2, Claude Sonnet,
4.5 Claude Opus 4.6 GR and Kim E 2.5.
There's that Kim E 2.5. Okay?
Yes, ALO exposes a rest API that uses both a public
and secret API key for authentication.
Uh, how the API Key Works AD requires two headers.
Uh, and these keys are generated per
account, should be kept private.
All right? Where to get your ad OAPI key.
All right, so here's my question. My question is this.
If I give the API key to open claw,
can it access, can it access my videos?
Can it grab the URL
and can it transcribe it?
That's all we wanna know. That's the part
that Vimeo is doing.
And we can very simply ask chat GBT or Perplexity, Orrock
or whatever, and it'll give us the
answer before we get in there.
And spin tokens trying to come up with the answers.
So yes, it can give you, uh,
it can give open claw your alo API keys.
It can access a lot depending on which endpoints it calls
and how you configure permissions.
Can it access your videos?
The alo API Lets a client list files, fetch files metadata,
and download project files when
authenticated with your keys.
So if Open Claw gives a valid, uh, key,
it can programably access any video
that those keys are allowed to access,
typically all in your account.
Can it grab the video? URL There is an endpoint
to download a project file by id.
Okay? A client with your keys can call that endpoint. Okay?
Can it transcribe? A dilo itself offers automatic
transcription and caption generation
and allows downloading subtitle transcript files.
If captions or transcripts already exist, an external tool
with your keys can pull those.
If you do not use a dill is built in transcription,
open clock and download your audio video
and run its own transcription engine.
Practically security implications,
giving your secret keys effectively giving open cloud back
and access to your Dilla Library view videos.
Download them, access existing subtitles.
You use them as input to other processes.
Only share keys with services you fully trust and possible.
Okay? So the answer is yes.
Everything that we did with, um,
everything we did with, uh, Vimeo,
we can do with a dello.
Now what about, uh, is it called Gum Road?
Is that what you guys said? Let me see.
Is, is that what you said? Gum lit.
Okay, gum lit, gum road, something else. What about gum lit?
All right, so let's see what, and,
and by the way, we can go find API docs for, uh,
that a dilo and just give the key
and the API docs to open claw.
But if you want that warm fuzzy feeling
before you get there, here you go with gum lit.
Same general risk applies if you give open claw
and API key with broad permissions.
It can access your videos. Does gum golet use APIs?
Golet does use APIs can open claw access your video URLs,
the gum lit video, API, lets a client create assets,
list assets get asset details.
Details include playback
and delivery URLs needed to stream or download a video.
Any service has an API queues video access
can call these endpoints.
Can it transcribed? Golet has AI powered subtitle
and transcript generation if transcript subtitles are
generated exposed via their APIs client
with appropriate permissions.
Okay? Uh, I'm not very technical.
Can you just simplify this? All right.
This is a big blessing for you guys. Think of your video.
API key, like a master key to your video account.
If you give that key to Open Cloud
and the principle, yes, it can see your videos, yes,
it can get the video URLs, yes, it can download video
or audio and transcribe it either using the hosting platform
built in transcripts if available,
or it has its own ai, right?
And that is for a
and gum lit, right?
Alright, so is everybody starting to understand this now?
Yes, that applies to both A and gum lit, right?
Uh, what other
Common platforms have
API Keys that Open Claw
might be able to use?
Alright, let's see.
Many of your big video hosts use API, keys, Vimeo,
Wistia, JW Player.
Um, let me see.
What I like about Perplexity is it doesn't just keep going
on and on and on and on and on.
It just gives you an answer, right?
What about other platforms that are not
video platforms?
Okay? This will get you guys thinking, right?
Most non-video tools work the same way.
Uh, email tools, uh, give me a list of them.
Here's a simple practical list.
A common platforms beyond video.
Were given Open Cloud, API key, it would access it.
Payments and billing. Stripe, PayPal, Braintree Charge.
Bree Recurly, paddle. That's the future guys.
Don't give it that. Uh, e-commerce platform.
Shopify, WooCommerce, BigCommerce, Magneto ec, wid, lights,
speech, future.
Don't give it access. Email marketing
and CRM, MailChimp, Klaviyo, SendGrid, ConvertKit, HubSpot,
Salesforce, Zoho, CRM at to campaign Entreport.
I'm gonna leave that up to you, right? What you want to do?
Analytics and ads, Google Analytics, Google Ads,
YouTube Analytics, Facebook ads, meta ads,
linked ads, Bing ads.
So you guys might notice in my, uh, welcoming, uh, message,
it tells me what my ad costs are.
Well, it's pulling, um,
it's pulling ad costs from Mint Bird.
Now, why would I want it from Mint Bird instead
of Facebook ads directly?
Well, you can give it a Facebook ads API key, okay?
But what I won't have is I won't know
what my sales are, okay?
Facebook reports sales through their, uh, conversion API,
but it's not very dependable right now when I have those
sales inside the Mint Bird Funnel versus the Ad Stats,
it's very, very dependable.
So I know that if I am acquiring a customer for $40
and making $90, then I'm making $50 profit.
I want it to report that every single day to me. Okay?
Analytics, yeah. Google Analyst, storage and content.
Look at this one guys. Google Drive, Dropbox, WordPress,
headless, CMS like Strappy, other SAS marketing tools,
author, uh, various unified, API, uh, OAuth, uh,
various API Tools, right?
Rule of thumb, if an app advertised an API
or developer API assume there's some sort of key or token
and any tool you can give that
that key can usually read or change that data.
Uh, and the key is allowed to touch guys, here it is.
That's the future. Do you understand?
That's what Open Claw is all about?
Is everybody getting this right now?
Now, I also want to, um, first of all, does that, does
that clarify how you can still take
all the work that we've done?
And you can go ahead
and, um, uh, load those zip files in there.
And even if it is using a platform like GC or, or, uh, Vimeo
or Dropbox, if we train it with Dropbox, uh,
which we're gonna get into this
week, I'll tell you what we're gonna do.
Um, then it's okay.
You can simply go and say, Hey, I don't have Vimeo,
but I have, uh, ALO and here's my API key.
Can you replace, um, uh, Vimeo with a,
does that make sense to everybody?
All and everything after it gets a video
and the transcript, everything after that is all the same.
So then once it gets a dillo,
and then once it, it finds a video, once it grabs a video,
URL, once it transcribed it, say, memorize
that, memorize that.
And I never ever wanna use Vimeo ever again.
Just get it outta your memory, okay?
Does, on a scale of one outta 10,
does everybody understand this right now?
So what I recommend you do is, uh,
I recommend that you talk to your AI platform
outside of Open Cloud.
Don't have these discussions here.
Always come up with your plan away from the tokens.
Guys, does that make sense? Talk to Chad.
GPT, talk to Perplexity. Talk to Grok.
Say, look, I'm thinking about doing this with Open Claw.
It understands. Talk to Claude. It understands.
Don't use your tokens to do that.
Come up with your game plan away from here.
Come up with your actions.
Come up with your training using Open Claw. Okay?
Um, now I wanna clarify something
because I had a lot of people reach out
to me in Total Panic this weekend,
and they said, Chad, your post, the founder of Open Claw,
he just went and sold out to OpenAI.
No, we didn't. No, we didn't.
Somebody else says that means that we're gonna have
to use Chad GPT, they're gonna turn off claw.
No, it doesn't read what it said.
OpenAI hired the founder.
They're gonna go build a more advanced model.
That doesn't mean that open clause going away.
It doesn't mean that it's being turned off.
It doesn't mean any of those things, right?
So that's the first thing we have to address.
Yeah, they hired him. Smart move, right?
Because there's a war with Meta and OpenAI.
So if OpenAI wants to get ahead of meta,
which Meta just opened theirs to
Mattis now has autonomous agents and memory and skills
and everything else, right?
Uh, but that's Facebook.
You'll be working through Messenger to do that, right?
It doesn't matter guys. It's here.
And just like I was one of the first ones
to introduce Chad gt, I did it on stage, right?
Because my friend Nick, crazy guy came to me.
Uh, he was one of the first hundred people to use Chad gt
'cause he was part of the founders' group.
And he said, I talked to God. Do you wanna talk to God?
I'm like, okay. And
that was the first time I'd ever heard about this thing
called GPT two or whatever it was.
And I told my partner at the time,
and we went out there and created the I bot.
And that's how that worked, right?
Well, that was brand new stuff back then.
Nobody had heard of Chad gpi.
Now the kids are using it in school.
Connie's using it to come up
with her color blends and everything.
It just, it caught on. It's just a part of life, right?
It's just a part of life. And those that are using, uh,
those that are are familiar, know that this is the year
of Claude, not GPT, right?
We know that, hey, uh, perplexity is a better model.
Claude is a better model.
We also know six to 12 months, supposedly they're gonna be,
AI's gonna be doing full stack software development, right?
We know these things that we're paying attention.
Well, the same way that this stuff is exciting right now,
guys, a year from now, this is gonna be the norm.
We won't even be talking about it.
We won't even be thinking about it. Does that make sense?
The days of entering your password
and logging into a software are gone.
It's a Titanic, man. That ship is sinking.
We are on that sinking ship right now. Okay?
So I, let's not panic over that.
You can't do anything about it anyways.
So you might as well ra ride the waves and,
and recognize the opportunity right now,
as I was putting together a presentation this weekend,
'cause a lot of people have asked me
to do that presentation.
I was given it this morning.
Um, I realized, uh, three things.
First of all, the, uh, founder, uh, the CEO
of Anthropic has said that we have reached the end
of exponential growth, which means everything
that we thought that we could do, we have been able to do.
And so now things are gonna start slowing down.
Now guys, what I was trying
to tell people in this presentation is, look,
you may have got behind.
You may have felt like you missed a train, right?
With, uh, you know, the vibe coding and,
and everything that AI can do
and autonomous agents, all this other stuff,
you may have felt like you missed it.
No, you didn't miss it. You just came in at the right time.
You came in when it counted, right?
You came in when AI was progressive.
So when it was reactive, you would ask,
it would give an answer, right?
Uh, but now it's proactive.
So it not only, uh, answers, it not only, uh,
solves the problem, but it thinks for you
before the problem happens, right?
We're in a proactive stage. So it's a good time.
But here's the other thing that I wanted
to emphasize in that presentation.
As an entrepreneur, you no longer have any choice.
Does everybody understand that?
You, you don't, you don't have a choice anymore,
but to be the one controlling the ai, does that make sense?
Quite frankly, I think that you guys are really,
really lucky being on this presentation.
I don't know what the rest of the world's gonna do.
I don't know what the rest of the marketplace is gonna do.
I don't know what VAs are gonna do. I just don't know.
I I honestly don't know.
Um, because they're not receiving the message that you need
to be the one controlling the ai.
And, and you guys, uh, you know,
it's like the train doors just open and that train's leaving
and you guys just snuck in right?
In the middle of. And so now you get to go on that journey
and, and keep up with it.
Keep up with it, right?
Entrepreneurs that, that successfully, that,
that truthfully wanna call themselves,
entrepreneurs have no choice but to pay attention.
Now. Now, the game has changed, guys.
Have you guys been feeling that lately?
The game has changed. Now we have to pay attention.
And that's the reason why I started paying attention.
I felt like everything up to this point was people playing.
It was a playground. Would you guys agree?
People were playing with Chad GPT and playing with images
and making their teddy bears?
Mm-hmm. Not no more pay attention.
And we're paying attention to software developers.
We're paying attention to everything we're building.
We're paying attention to everything that we're integrating.
We're paying very, very close attention
to the things that we're teaching.
to the messages that we're giving.
'cause it's a very, very important vital time, uh,
in the world, especially for entrepreneurship.
All right? So here's what we're gonna do.
I hope that message reached you guys.
Uh, g can you gimme the API Docs for Global Control?
I think we put it out there once we have made some changes
to those docs where it's going to be more accepted, uh,
inside of our, um, open Claw account.
And, uh, by the way, before I do that, uh, let me go ahead
and, uh, show you what we're gonna do.
We're gonna give you guys the command for Moonshot.
Moonshot is the platform that has the Kim E 2.5.
You guys wanna go get an API key for Kim E 2.5.
We're gonna give you the command today,
and you're gonna go ahead and load that
inside of your open claw.
And it's going to install ME 2.5.
It should not break because we have tested this over
and over and over and over, okay?
You want that because it's gonna reduce your cost by 85%.
Now, this is what I was trying to tell you guys earlier.
We spent the money to train
and build out the AP API docs perfectly.
You guys don't have to.
I was shown this morning that it went
and created an article that fast.
It wasn't even a penny. You guys hear me?
It wasn't even a penny. It did it from blank. Okay?
So when you create an article now, it'll ask you,
do you want to use Letterman's feature?
Do you want to create it from
blank where I create it for you?
Now, Letterman has an incredible feature
that now it tells you what keywords you can rank
for if you're integrated with Josh's platform,
it'll even tell you what the search volume is
for those keywords and the difficulty and the trend.
So you might wanna use Letterman's, uh, uh,
Letterman's feature, okay?
But if you don't, then you're totally relying on Open Claw
to write that blank article.
And if you're using C Claude, right,
then it's gonna do a great job, okay?
Especially with 4.6 rolling out.
So you're also relying on it
to do all the SEO for you and everything else.
Does that make sense? So people using Letterman,
we built all that SEO functionality in there.
If you wanna do it from blank, then you're relying on Claude
to do all of that stuff for you
and come up with the keywords for you
and everything else, Claude,
or whatever model you're using, Kimmy 2.5 or whatever.
Okay? So all that work that we've done
where we just hand you the zip file,
we've done all the work, we've made it work with the APIs,
we spent the money to do it.
Now you, when you get clear on
what it is you wanna do in your business, how many
of you're starting to get clear right now?
Because I'm talking to two people.
I'm talking to people that have always
done things in their business, and they've listened to me
and they've hired VAs over the year.
I always had a a VA process to do that, to get, you know,
cheap VAs or whatever.
And, and I always had a process to train the VAs
and I taught that to you guys for years, right?
So there's those people that knew the, uh, emails needed
to get sent out and,
and, uh, you know, maybe they're doing replays,
maybe they're doing social media, like whatever.
There's those people that knew that
and see the opportunity to have, um, open claw,
do all those things for them without fail.
Okay? There's those people.
But then there's other people that
have been paying attention,
have been hearing about lead steps
and hearing about pop links and,
and hearing about creating your own system, process,
method, strategy, secret formula.
There's those people, okay?
But maybe you were technically challenged
or maybe you had head monsters.
Maybe you got in your own way
and you didn't, you never created the lead step as
as easy as I made it.
Or, or maybe you never set up the tag as easy as I made it.
Well, now that takes care of you too.
Now you have no excuse. 'cause now you're just physically
saying, can you create a tag?
Not only that, I don't even think you have to go that far.
I think you can simply, if you know two words,
I think you can simply say to your, uh, open claw, Hey,
can we create a sign up page for my event this weekend?
And it's to say, sure, what's your event about?
Uh, my event is about using AI in business. Perfect.
It creates that, uh, by the way, Chad, I created a tag
for you, uh, called event, uh, dash two 16.
Um, do we want an email to go out?
Yeah, let's go ahead and set up an email. Boom.
Do you guys understand it can start coaching you?
You don't coach it, it can start coaching you. Okay?
Um, that's pretty exciting.
So look, I was at, um, uh, I, I, I was at, uh,
uh, village Pub, uh, this weekend,
and, uh, I was getting a, um, a steak for breakfast.
And, uh, I was sitting across from, uh, Jace, right?
Our boy. And, uh, he's, he's getting ready to turn 14.
And he says, Hey, uh, Chad, uh, would you agree
that I'm old enough and responsible enough to get one
of those motorized bikes?
I'm like, you're not dragging me into this.
'cause Mama clearly said no, right?
I was like, by the way, how much are those things? $1,200.
$1,200, okay?
So, uh, if you have straight A's, I'll get that for you.
But you don't have straight A's do you?
If your mama says, it's okay, I will get the bike for you.
But you don't have straight A's, do you? No. Okay.
Well, how are you gonna make the money then?
Well, uh, what I was thinking is I would go out there
and clean trash cans, uh, one for $25
or two for 40.
Okay, that sounds like a good idea.
So have you done the math?
If you're, uh, cleaning trash cans for 25 each
or two for 40, have you figured out
how many trash cans you gotta clean to come up with
that 700, $1,200 thing?
I just heard 'em say, are you serious in the other room?
You don't want me telling this story?
Come over here and help me tell the story.
No, this is a good story. All right.
So, um, I'm, I'm sitting down talking to him
and I'm saying, dude, look man, there's an easier way
to do this, right?
So look, he plays baseball, he's good at baseball.
He's played, he plays guitar, he's good at guitar,
but you know what he's really, really good at, guys.
He's really, really good at video games,
really good at video games.
So I took out my phone
and I asked Chad, GPT,
now I want you guys to understand this right now.
I took out my phone and I asked Chad G, pt, I said,
and let me see if I can find it here,
and I'll show you guys, uh, can I show him your cover?
I'll show him the nice cover I was playing too.
But, um, I asked Chachi pt, I said,
what are the top video games out there?
And it said that there was, uh, Roblox,
it said that there was Fortnite.
Um, and, uh, it said some, uh, some other ones, right?
I said, okay, cool. So then I asked it, I said,
can you go ahead and create me a secret guide for Roblox?
And it went through and went, and of course, all this stuff
that I know, uh, absolutely nothing about.
Let me see if I can find it here. So it did that.
And then, uh, I said, okay, uh,
can you go ahead, let me see if I can find it for you guys.
Can you go ahead and create me, uh, cover
for Roblox Secrets by, uh,
Jace Perez, right?
And within 10 seconds, guys,
I don't know if you could see this,
but I'm gonna turn this down.
Within 10 seconds, it went and created that cover.
So now he's got the cover, now he's got the secrets.
And now I said, okay, we came back home
and I open up perplexity
and I said, can you find me if you go search for Roblox
or Grand Theft Auto
or whatever, can you find me the top 10
videos that have the most views?
And we sat there and we watched these videos, right?
And we watched 'em and just kids playing games
or whatever, 3 million views, 5 million views or whatever.
I'm like, Jace, do that. Go upstairs.
That PlayStation will record your video.
Start recording these videos.
And then, son, you need to learn how
to make sure the videos you're recording are
what people are searching for.
And see, AI today will tell you that we can ask Claude,
we can ask chat, GPT, we can ask whatever,
uh, we can ask it.
What should I be shooting videos on
that people are searching for?
And then shoot those videos.
And then once you're done with that video, then
what we're gonna do is we're gonna turn around,
we're gonna take that video and we're gonna create a title,
and we're gonna create a description.
And then you're gonna get a domain,
and you're gonna give away your, uh, grand Theft Auto Guide
or your Roblox guide or whatever it is.
And you're gonna build a list,
and you can build a very, very big list so
that you have a list where you're able
to mail out every single day.
And some days you'll provide value.
Some days you'll tell people,
when you have a new video coming up,
other days you're gonna put a link in
there and you're gonna make sales.
And this is what you need to do.
And you don't need to be out there cleaning
trash cans and stuff.
And, and, and then what's gonna happen?
And please listen to me.
Guys, what's gonna happen naturally is as you're learning
to create these videos, and as you're learning
to build this list, and as you're write writing these emails
and creating these pages and, and learning about SEO
and optimization and everything else,
other kids are gonna look at you
and they're gonna say, wow,
how in the world do I learn how to do that?
And then what happens is you can bring 'em on a webinar
and you can show 'em everything
that you figured out for your business.
Does that make sense? So when I keep telling everybody,
figure out your own system, process, methods, strategy,
secret formula, that kid can now go upstairs
and just sit there and, and play video games all day.
The PlayStation will record it.
He just needs to make sure that he is showing the things
that people are looking for,
and he has that guide that he can go out there
and give away for free to build a list.
Do you guys understand this?
And now, the part that we haven't figured out yet,
we're gonna figure it out this week, is now we take the
video, we put it up inside a Dropbox,
and then Open Claw goes into Dropbox, grabs the video,
transcribes the video, goes into the YouTube,
API creates a video, creates the se optimized description,
creates the long description, puts the link in there,
then it takes that video, uses something like Opus Clip,
cuts that video up into little pieces,
and then it goes out there
and puts it on TikTok, Instagram, YouTube shorts,
and wherever else it can.
Is everybody starting to get this right now?
Type in the chat on a scale of one outta 10, how many
of you are starting to get this
simple model right now?
Guys, I'm gonna tell you right now, it's the same thing.
So with Ja, I'm trying to, uh, communicate on a level that,
that he likes, that, that
that feels good at 14 years old, right?
It could be that he could teach people how to play guitar.
It could be that he could teach people baseball tactics.
It doesn't matter. Now, what I said to him is, I said, look,
I'm doing the same exact thing.
People are hot on ai.
This open Cloth thing came out
and I did exactly what you did with video games.
I cracked the code. I I practiced
till I got really, really good.
And then what did I do? I started showing people
that I got really, really good.
And then what happened? I turned around
and I wrote a guide, right?
I, I wrote this guide,
and then from there, everybody
started signing up for the guide.
And then a certain number of those people that signed up
for the guide paid me $497 to be on this call right now.
And so now what could I do?
I could take all the videos that I've been shooting
and I could cut them up and I could load them up on YouTube
and everything else because
everybody's searching for open clock.
Does that make sense? Type in the chat.
Let me know if you get this. So right now I'm talking
to the people that have never had the business
that just don't understand that part of it.
And I'm saying now, open Claw is going to remove that
because every single day Jace could wake up,
especially if he doesn't have school like today,
and it could say, Hey, here's your top, uh, here's your top,
uh, video topics that you should shoot a video for.
Let me know when you get 'em done.
Three videos are there, right?
So he shoots the videos, he comes back, says, okay,
I put 'em in Dropbox for you.
Boom. It takes over. It takes over, right?
And now people are watching the video.
Now they're clicking the link. Now they're uh,
downloading his guide, right?
And then what happens? Now he can say to Open Cloud, Hey,
uh, the new Grand Theft Auto,
the 3.0 just came out or whatever.
Uh, can you go get me an affiliate link on Amazon? Boom.
Now he does. Alright, do me a favor, write an email, uh,
and share these three secrets in that email.
Make sure you put my affiliate link there
and then boom, it mails that out.
Do you guys understand? And he could just talk to it.
He could just talk to it now.
Yeah, he'll do good with the video game stuff, guys.
Of course he will. There's a bigger picture here.
Wow, a 14-year-old out there running AI in open claw.
What an incredible opportunity, isn't it?
Uh, people are gonna pay attention to them.
They might not pay attention to me. I'm 50 years old.
They're gonna pay attention to a 14-year-old. Makes sense.
Alright, good.
So, uh, how many of you have already got the, um, uh,
Kimmy 2.5
and Kenny Johnson, your command
that you're looking claw you're looking for
is open claw gateway, restart.
Okay, so Craig has it. Uh, who else does anybody else have?
Type in Kimmy if you have it.
Kimmy 2.5, by the way,
G is that what we're gonna run on today is Kimmy 2.5?
Yeah, I can do that.
All right. You guys wanna see it? Yep.
You gotta get through Moonshot.
So you guys go through Moonshot.
Um, and remember, once you have loaded all the zip files
and everything for you guys to, when you figure out
what it is you're doing, and I'm trying to, when Im trying
to coach you with what you could be doing, uh, understand
that your costs are minimal, your costs are minimal
because you're not training it,
it's just running on its own.
Okay? So if I come over here, if I look at, uh,
this screen here, all right, see,
that wasn't so bad, was it, Jace?
All right, so if we look at it here, uh,
I wanna show you guys something.
Uh, actually I haven't seen this one yet.
Uh, created three generated AI articles.
Uh, title appears.
Okay, we'll figure out what's going on there,
but, uh, I was showing this this morning,
but there was something I woke up to
that I thought was pretty cool.
So let me see if I can find it here for you.
Look at this here. So overnight,
bill complete built tonight, zoom webinar scopes guide,
step-by-step to fix yesterday's API permission.
So last night I asked it to create a webinar for Thursday
and it said I'm missing these permissions.
I'm like, whatever. Zoom Webinar workflow,
full API, docs with PowerShell.
Examples, create webinars and registrants.
Um, today, Tuesday, webinar config pre-built, how
to finally run your entire business with ai.
Tuesday, February 18th, 10:00 AM Pacific Standard Time,
90 minute cloud recording, qa ready
to create instantly when scopes are enabled.
Still waiting on your newsletter.
Hour bullets, uh, GC guys, I'm gonna tell you right now,
I can't, I can't keep up with it.
I'm so used to, uh, asking for something to be done
and then, um, having a follow up.
I'm not used to, I'm not used
to something being this proactive.
It is taken me a minute.
I was on a call this morning trying to show the CanBan board
that we built and I couldn't remember my password
that we set up and so I'm fumbling around or whatever.
And then Karthik finally says,
why don't you just ask Open Claw what the password is?
I'm like, you're right. So I asked it,
it is like, boom, here it is.
I'm just, I'm not used to that yet.
I don't know if you guys are getting used to it,
but it's gonna take me a minute to work with something that
that is that proactive.
So on Friday, I was telling Connie
because she's so busy with her consultations, um, I,
I was trying to show her how it created a newsletter
and I didn't answer properly
and we were both sick and frustrated.
So I just threw my phone down. I said, uh, I'm done.
I'm not gonna, I'm not gonna work at all this weekend.
I'm gonna see if I can get better for you guys.
Well I at 11 o'clock at night, it,
I got this message on my phone.
I happened to look at it, it said overnight build, complete
what I built while you slept content queue system
for West Valley Shoutouts problem Solve.
Yesterday when you said write West Valley articles,
I kept asking what the topic was.
You were frustrated.
It's getting to know me a little bit, right?
You were frustrated. It says I should know how
to find the topics myself.
So the solution, I created a research article Q with 10,
ready to write topics from this week's local news.
How do you say write number one?
I create full article with image.
Say write the pull one, same thing. No more what's it about?
Questions also created article templates
for every event type, business,
community, restaurants, et cetera.
Okay, so, uh, then it says, happy Valentine's Day.
Do you want me to write article number two?
Alright, I'll be honest with you guys.
We have trained it mentally.
I am blocked in my head
'cause I don't know how to work with
something that's proactive.
I'm just not used to it.
Is there anybody else that is feeling that way at all?
Is there anybody else feeling that way at all?
It's taken me a minute.
I've trained it to do so much
and now I'm having a hard time letting go of my old ways
that I've had for the last 15 years.
It's a bit of a struggle for me, right?
And I'm the incompetent one in the puzzle right now.
It's like, Hey, what are your bullets?
Hey, I gotta update this. Hey, we got this thing on Thursday
and I'm going, wait a minute, I'm not used
to going at this speed.
So what do I do?
'cause I feel stupid and I can't keep up with it.
I walk away from it, right? So it is gonna take a minute.
I think it's gonna take a minute for you guys too.
It's a good problem to have, right?
It's just, it's it's,
it's better than I thought it was gonna be.
It really truly is. Okay, so let's go ahead.
Um, uh, do you know what the command is g
Uh, do you know what the command is
to find out what model we're on?
You can do first less model or you can just ask it. Yeah.
So we do like that four slash model.
Yeah. Okay.
So right now we're on Claude Opus 4.5.
All right, so I'm gonna ask you to switch to Kimmy.
No, you gotta run the command.
Okay? We haven't run the command yet.
Yeah. Okay. Do you have the API key and all that?
Um, it'll ask for the API key after that,
but I can give you the API key.
All right? So gimme the command and gimme the API key.
Okay? Uh, it'll be on your dm.
Perfect.
Uh, let's see. On my dm, not in this chat, I imagine.
Okay, let me see. I can find that.
Yeah, let me know what you sent it.
Um, do we see it on your DM now? I just sent you
Uh, on my regular Zoom chat.
Yeah, on your dm.
Okay, let me see. Okay, got it. All right.
So I'm gonna go ahead and um, put this command here.
Install the Kimmi model, moonshot kimmi 2.5 qmi, uh,
K two thinking Qmi coating K two PP five,
pulling the latest versions available, verifying check sums,
registering them in the local model registry
and confirming they're available for inference.
Once installation of verification are complete, prompt me
to enter Kimmi 2.5 to configure authentication.
Do not proceed with API. Key intel setup is provided.
All right, so I'm gonna go ahead and give it this.
Do you wanna put that in the chat so they can do it with us?
Yeah,
So again, you gotta go to that moon link.
You gotta get your, uh, okay, quick clarification.
Kimmy models are API based moonshot, API,
not local models that need downloading.
There's nothing to install locally.
Just API configuration available models.
The model name you mentioned, uh, doesn't match endpoints.
They might be internal beta names ready to configure.
Please provide your, okay, go ahead and,
and, uh, I'll put this API key in here
so we can just ignore all that stuff.
G.
Yep. And you're seeing that preview
because you're in telegram.
I don't think it shows up that way.
Okay, so let me go ahead and grab this key.
Yeah, I am te I am in telegram, by the way guys,
I'm not in the server.
We could jump in the server if we need to.
Um, so you can see it says get one at platform Moonshot did
cm, you don't wanna do the cn, that's China.
Um, app moonshot do ai.
I think there's um, a different link too, right?
You put that in the chat. All right,
so it's grabbing the API key.
We'll use that for this session
and then we're gonna change it.
Uh, Kimmy model install provider moonshot ai, uh,
switch this session to Kimmy
or specify Gateway Restarted successfully.
Kimmy models are now live and ready for reference.
So I'm gonna go ahead and say forward slash model.
We're still on anthropic, Claude Opus 4.5
and uh, browse more model.
Uh, is there a, um, switch? Yeah, so we can do
Switch. Um, you see where it
says to to use,
it's giving you the option you can do first,
less model KI 30 2K.
Okay, so I'll just say switch.
Yeah, let's see what happens.
But there, this is the command here too.
We can do switch, switch colon, uh, kidney 2.5.
Okay, so, uh, test me out. I'm on Chinese AI now.
So is this a 30 2K? Is this the best one?
Uh, there's one more above this. That's 1 28 K
Oh 2 1 28 K.
Alright, yeah, I see it now.
Uh, okay, so I'm gonna say this.
Yeah, it's this one right here. So let's try this.
So we're gonna say, um, switch
and then, uh, we're gonna go like this.
Oops, not that one.
I want kimmi 1, 2, 8 K, okay,
KIMI 1, 2, 8 K.
Okay, switch kimmi. 1, 2, 8 K.
All right, let's see if that works. That's
how you switch models or you can just tell it.
Uh, did I do that wrong?
Switch colon.
I think the, um, the model that you switched
to is having the problem.
Okay, so we'll do the other one. The 30 2K.
Yeah, give me a minute. Uh,
it's not gonna respond to you anymore.
Oh, I broke it. Well, hold on a second.
Share what you're doing when we broke it.
So this is what we've been trying to avoid, guys.
Uh, and we've tested this over and over and over.
Do you wanna share your screen, G?
Yeah. Okay. So he's gonna have
to restart the gateway, right?
No, I gotta change the configure.
Is that something that we just do for them
or is that something they can do?
Uh, we don't usually run into that problem,
but this Kimmi has problem with that last model.
It's their problem. They gotta fix it.
Okay, so share your screen. So I
Just, I just recommend that don't use 1 28
right now that's having the problem.
Okay. Um, we had it, we had this problem.
This, this was the thing guys, this is, I've been wanting
to bring Kimmy to you
and the team keeps telling me, no, no, no, don't do it yet.
Every time we do it, it breaks.
Every time we do it, it breaks. Okay? Um, yeah,
And we thought everything was fixed.
Now we used it, but we never switched to 1 28 uses date.
I thought it would work, but it didn't. So,
Okay, so the 30 2K is good.
Yeah, 30 2K is good. So yeah.
All right. So yeah, you're having
to go really heavy in here.
So whenever you guys, um,
have problems installing the model, what I recommend is
that you just raise your hand
and let us try to fix that for you.
Does that make sense? Because at this point,
normally, uh, open clock,
it go fix itself except we have disconnected it.
So if you've disconnected it
and you've done the gateway restart, that didn't work.
Uh, you did the doctor repair
that didn't work, the doctor fixed.
None of that stuff worked. You are probably better off
letting us go in there and help you like he's doing now.
Does that, and I, and by the way, I have no desire to learn
what it is he's doing right now.
Right? Okay. Gee, that's a little bit technical for me.
So, um, I'll go ahead and, uh, share my screen again.
Did everybody, did everybody get that message?
By the way, if you are having any problems, is there anybody
that is completely disconnected?
I'll, I'll tell you the one time, the one time
that you will not be able to restart the gateway,
you will not be able to fix things, is if you try
to add that model.
If you try to add a different, uh, AI model
and it breaks, that's where you're kind of screwed, okay?
So that's why we've been really,
really cautious about introducing a new model to you.
But I really do want to because, uh, it's very,
very effective and the savings is really, really good.
Okay? So let me know when I'm good to go again, g
And while we're waiting for that,
what questions do you guys have up to this point?
Yep. Use the 30 2K. Don't do the 1 28 K, right? G?
Yeah, don't do the last one. Everything else would work.
Yep. So do you can do the eight k, you can do the 30 2K.
Okay. But just stay clear
of the 1 28 K till they fix something.
Alright? Uh, let me see. Do we have any questions?
If you guys have questions, type in the chat
or if you wanna share some experiences up to this point.
Something you've done.
I've been trying to keep up with all the, um, all the, uh,
comments that you guys post in the WhatsApp room.
I've been seeing some pretty cool stuff happening.
Uh, what's the minimum amount to fund the Kimmy 2.5?
Do you know the answer to that, G?
Can you say that again sir?
What is the minimum amount to fund 2.5?
The Kimmy 2.5? Is it five
20? I think, I
think minimum is $5.
Minimum is $5. Okay.
Um, can you restart from Telegram?
You can if it's currently connected. Sure.
You saw it restart when?
See, right here, gateway restarted successfully, right?
It did that when I was inside a telegram.
Uh, okay, so minimum is $5. What else?
So do we go to platform moonshot.ai from our
laptop or from the VPs?
You'll do it from your laptop.
All you're trying to do is get an API key,
then you gonna fund that API key.
Okay. What else?
Uh, mine is saying I have to restart manually.
Well, you know how to do that, so try to do it.
And if you get stuck, you put your hand up.
Oh man. Let me ask you guys a question real quick while
we're waiting for G and then we'll train this GC thing on.
Uh, we'll use Kimmy 30 2K today.
But let me ask a question, guys.
Do you think, even though this is pretty techy, um,
are you guys surprised that you got this far with it
having a, having a VPS and running commands?
And is, is it a little bit easier than
what you thought it was gonna be?
My bank, I don't know what a bank is.
My bank didn't like the moonshot platform purchase.
Can I Oh, your bank, your actual physical bank. Yeah.
Uh, can I do this without yet paying moja?
I don't know if I was you, I wouldn't be asking Chad.
I'd be asking perplexity.
Chad is no longer the smart one.
I've always been the smart one, but not no more. Right?
I'd ask, I'd ask one of your AI
platforms that question, right?
Uh, so James says a hundred percent good. Yeah.
People think I'm crazy. They're like, you are crazy
for taking people that don't have a lot
of technical experience
and setting 'em up on VPSs and training 'em all this.
I'm like, no, we have patience
and if something breaks, we're there to fix it.
Right? This is way easier
because you're doing the hard work for us.
Yeah. But you guys are learning at the same time too, right?
We're teaching you how to fish.
How are we looking, g Did we break it? We're good.
Who is actually talking to Kimmy right now? Anybody
who is talking to Kimmy?
30 2K or eight K? Anybody?
Alright. Um, while I'm still waiting for G uh,
let me show you guys, uh, what you can expect,
I think by tomorrow.
Uh, let me go to the front end here by tomorrow.
What I will do, what I will put there for you, um,
is I'll have a new section down here
where we start getting into the apps.
So even though it says step,
these are chapters I need to rename it, right?
Or I could just tell open cada, go rename 'em, I guess.
Um, but there'll be a new one.
There'll be a chapter four where I will start outlining,
uh, what you need to do in great detail with your GitHub,
um, with your cel, how to connect those, um,
how all that works so
that you can very easily start building apps.
Um, 'cause I know not everybody likes
I've heard all the complaints.
Not everybody likes going through these replays, um,
and learning how to do stuff.
Okay? So, um, I've just been waiting to get a better voice,
uh, and then I'll be able to do it, right?
So, let's see, uh, this way, okay, trying to pay for it.
Yep. He was trying to pay for it.
His bank did not like dealing with a Chinese company.
Um, so I used to use something, guys
that might come in handy for you.
Uh, I, I need to use it again.
Has anybody heard of privacy.com?
Has anybody heard of this at all?
privacy.com is really, really cool
because what you could do is you can come in here
and add all of your SaaS platforms,
and what it'll do is it'll give you a virtual card for
that SaaS platform.
And so what's awesome about it is you can come over here,
you can get away with things on like Facebook
and, you know, my bank doesn't like Chinese,
you know, companies, whatever.
Um, and you can give it a virtual card,
but what I love about it is,
I don't know if you guys have ever played the game where
you wanna call up and cancel a service
and you can't get it done, can't find a customer support
number, and then they bill you again, they bill you again.
Well, when you use a virtual card on Vimeo
or you know, a dello or, or these AI platforms
or whatever you're doing, you can simply go in there
and cancel the virtual card and that stops all billing
because they don't have your real credit card number.
I'm sure there's more services like this.
I've used this one for a long time.
I need to get back to using it.
When I created the new company, the old company went away,
but the old company was using a lot of this.
I need to get back to this because you're not stuck
with reoccurring charges.
You can cancel it whenever you want to.
And here's the other thing.
How many of you have ever had a surprise reoccurring charge?
Has anybody ever had a surprise reoccurring charge?
And you're like, what the hell is that?
Like, I know AWeber is infamous for this right now.
They took people that are paying like $19 a month
and took 'em to $200 a month, right?
Well, with privacy.com, the other thing is,
you can set a limit for that card
and you can say, I'm authorizing $30 a month, and that's it.
And no more than that. Okay?
Now, I probably, you know what?
I just thought of that I probably would be comfortable
giving access to privacy.com.
Let me, so let's go ahead and,
and let's test out my theories and, and how we look.
G I'm trying to buy you some time here. Uh, let's see.
Perplexity, where did I put that? Uh, here we go. All right.
Does privacy.com using
API or token?
And by the way, G, if you're talking, you're muted.
All right, let's see what we got. privacy.com.
Yes. privacy.com provides a developer, API
and it uses API tokens for authentication.
They have a developer, API you can use program.
We can create and manage virtual cards. Perfect.
So check this out.
Open Clock could go into your privacy
and it could create a card for you.
It could make a payment for you.
It could look and give you a report every single day
of any transactions that are happening.
But let me ask it this, uh, I want
to make sure it doesn't access
my bank or real credit cards.
Only virtual.
So I'm gonna say, I wanna make sure, uh,
open Claw doesn't.
So you guys gotta talk to it, right?
You're on the right track.
Using privacy.com is exactly
how you keep open claw away from your real cards.
What to do Only connect Open Claw to privacy.com,
not your bank or real card.
Give open claw privacy API token, never your bank
or real credit card number.
Use only virtual cards.
Create one or more virtual cards in privacy.com
that are dedicated to Open Claw charges.
Those virtual cards sit in your front
of your real bank account, so merchants
and tools never see your actual card number.
Lock down the virtual cards set spending limits per month
or transaction on those cards.
Optionally, lock a card to a specific merchant
and pause or close it anytime.
If you feel anything weird.
If you want, tell me how you're planning to pay Open Claw.
And I can suggest, um, what I would like to be
able to do is have open
claw where it can retrieve the card
for me, possibly
make a payment on demand
if need be, and
be able to give me a report, a daily
report, or on demand
report if I inquire
about, uh, charges.
Okay. However, once again,
I do not want it to have my bank
or real, uh,
credit card info.
All right. Are you there, G?
Yeah, I'm here. Are we looking,
Uh, still working on it? Give it a minute.
Okay. You can get exactly what you want
with privacy.com while still keeping open Claw away
from your real credit cards.
What Open Claw can do safely if you give open claw
privacy.com API token, not bank access, it can create
and manage virtual cards only within the limits you set.
It can see card details
and make payments using those virtual cards.
For example, pay a subscription on demand.
It can list transactions to generate daily
or on demand reports of charges
by calling the transactions endpoint.
All of this happens on top of privacy.com merchants
and Open Claw never sees your real bank login
or real card numbers.
How to keep real accounts hidden.
Connect your real bank account only to privacy.com.
Not to open claw. Give open claw one, dedicated API token,
and use it only for creating virtual cards, making payments
with those virtual cards and reading transaction history.
And for extra safety set, spending limits
and rules on each card, uh, per transaction or total.
So if something goes wrong, it cannot overspend.
All right, is there other
services like privacy,
uh, dot com that has the APIs?
All right, can you talk to perplexity? You can.
I don't know if it'll talk back to you though.
Yes, there are several services to privacy.com
that issue virtual cards.
And for business or developer plans,
typically offer APIs or integrations.
So another tool can create cars, set limits
and read transactions.
Examples, if you're looking at features, availability, defer
by country personal versus business ramp Mercury.
I, I have Mercury too, guys. I have Mercury too.
Mercury's really good Waller, clutch, moon,
some FinTech banks, because details change
and depend heavily on your country and business statute.
First, the safest approach is decide if you need personal
or business virtual cards.
Check each provider's, developers
or API page to confirm they follow, creating,
controlling virtual cards, reading transaction history.
Use the same pattern you described.
Connect open claw only to the virtual card service.
Is that helping you guys? Are you guys starting
to understand how you can find APIs that are safe,
but very, very effective?
There's always a work around, right?
So I never want this thing to have access to my bank.
I never want this thing to have access
to a real credit card,
but I would love to be able to say, Hey, uh,
can you go pay the server bill?
You see, how amazing would that be?
That would be pretty incredible. Do you guys agree
it can do all that stuff for you?
Does that make sense? Is
everybody starting to get this now?
Uh, switched to Kimmy Cloth, said all.
Okay, then I got a 4 0 1.
Uh, uh, if you ask it, what model it's on,
Sherry, is it still on a model?
I, I'm telling you guys, man,
we tested this a hundred different times.
You guys kept asking for this model
and I kept saying, Nope, nope.
We need to, uh, we, we need to look into it more.
Um, pne, can you go look
and see if you can rein re restart her Gateway for her?
Yeah. Okay. He'll look into it, Sherry.
Uh, so we're, we'll, we'll get past that.
And, and by the way, guys, the way that we're, uh,
installing things today,
it's gonna be a lot easier in the future.
They'll just have it where you click a button,
it'll be done, right?
Are there certain things we should do with Kimmy and others?
Uh, with Claude? Not necessarily.
Um, if it's trained, if the AI's trained, it can handle it.
It's gonna go through, it's gonna read your files.
That's what we've been testing.
We have been seeing that, uh, from what I saw last week,
the Kimmi model is almost equivalent to the Opus 4.5,
but way cheaper.
Way cheaper, okay?
Uh, what other questions do you guys have?
privacy.com. That's a nice little added bonus.
Uh, what other questions while we're waiting
to get back online here,
good questions, by the way.
What else Does anybody want to share?
Something that they've done?
Just to save my voice, a little bit of hoarseness here.
Uh, let's see
who's creating articles, who's creating courses?
Can we install the VPS and train it on QE 2.5?
I don't understand what that means.
Yeah, you can train on Kimmy 2.5 for sure.
It's just an AI model. Yeah, it's just an ai.
Everything that we've been doing, uh, with Opus 4.5,
sonnet 4.5, you can do with Kimmi 2.5.
So what we, we did was obviously Opus is the big dog. Okay?
Now, 4.6 is out there. Okay?
So what we did, guys,
is we trained it on the very best model there was.
So when it was writing the files and everything, okay,
and we showed that to you guys last time,
it was writing those files based off the best model.
Okay? So if I write those files, if I train
with Kimmy 2.5 is gonna write those files, maybe it's just
as good, maybe it's not right.
But now that it's trained, it doesn't really matter.
You can go out there and you can go ahead and,
and, uh, run those files all you want, right?
Uh, good question.
So my friend, uh, Nick introduced me to,
uh, mercury.
Lemme make sure I'm not logged in. I don't think I am.
Uh, so if you just go to mercury.com, I love
how you guys ask questions.
What I keep telling you, don't ask me, go ask, uh,
go ask Claude or go ask Perplexity or something.
Um, mercury.com is a virtual bank.
Uh, you will actually open up an account right here.
Uh, there's no office for you to, to walk into
or anything else.
Uh, you could set up business, uh, accounts with it.
Uh, it's really good. It's instant approval.
They'll send you a card in the mail.
You'll have a regular login. They have an app.
Um, I don't know. That to me is a real bank.
I don't know if I would give access to Open Claw.
I don't know if I would give it mercury.com,
but I would certainly give it privacy.com.
And the reason why is because I know
that I can set up limits on those cards, right?
And, and again, you would,
you could just have one card if you just wanted to pay all
of your SaaS bills.
Let's say that, man, I don't know how many instances
of AI we have now.
We're, we're paying for perplexity, we're paying for, uh,
we have two instances of chat, GBT, uh,
now we're paying $200 a month for a clo
so we can do the Claude code, right?
Um, we have all these different charges.
So I could go
and create, uh, separate virtual card for a Claude
for Philanthropic versus open ai,
or I could just have an AI card,
and the only thing that would hit
that card would be AI expenses.
Then I can have another card for the outsourcers, right?
Does that make any sense to you guys?
So you can create a, a separate virtual card
for each merchant, or you could just have one
card for the whole category.
Okay? Uh, do we still need Stripe using privacy.com?
Yes. So Stripe is what you would use to be able
to take payments like in member
or go high level or something like that.
Mercury.com is a virtual bank, right?
It's a virtual bank and money goes in, money goes out
through a card, EFT, uh, whatever that is
where you say we need a new API key for gc.
You don't need a new API key.
Uh, you don't even need new um, docs.
It's just we had to make changes to the docs for it
to be able to read it better, right?
I assume you're on remote desktop as I got logged out. Yeah.
Uh, I should have warned you on that.
Sherry pne just logged in your account.
He's trying to get you back up. Okay.
Uh, how are we looking here, G?
Yeah, it's back online.
And I'm gonna give you a new prompt real quick,
Okay? So that
people don't have the same problem.
I don't wanna cough on you guys. Hold on.
All right. Sorry for the delays. Thanks, Dan.
So how is Chad and nicely generating images on articles?
Okay, so, uh,
you guys can ask your open AI if it has image,
Jen, just ask it.
Say or ask your open claw.
Do you have image gen installed?
Okay, ask it that question. Image gen. All right?
See if it tells you yes or no.
If you added your open AI key, uh, it should be able
to create images, uh, for you.
I trained the, uh, article file
to create images for you.
But if it doesn't recognize, that's one thing
that's a little confusing to me, g, is if I ask it,
do you have Image Gen installed?
It says yes. So how come it just doesn't know
that on its own mine it is using Splash.
And I never even asked it to. I thought you did this. No.
Uh, um, what is Splash splash.com?
Hold on, let's see what you figured out with that.
Um, unless pne asked it to use splash.com. Let me see.
splash.com. Splash, is it splash.com?
Splash, splash,
type in Splash Images, maybe Unsplash.
Is it Unsplash? We have used Unsplash.
If you're talking about Unsplash, we've used that.
Um, so yeah, it could find free ones on Unsplash.
Uh, you know what's interesting?
Oh, you know what's really interesting? Hold on.
I'm, I'm gonna, I'm gonna share
one more thing with you guys.
Let's see if we can figure this one out.
If we come over here to, uh,
you know, you know, another cool thing
that I was thinking about, uh, here in the States, uh,
we have our credit score too.
I could probably get an update, um,
from my open clock every morning if something
hits my credit report.
And there's probably, uh,
I use something called Smart Credit.
There's probably an API to that where, uh,
open clock can make sure
that there's nothing hitting my credit report, right?
Just another example. Um, what about the stock photos
sites like Unsplash,
uh, deposit photo I stock.
You don't, you guys don't ever want to use iStock.
Uh, there's other ones.
Do they have APIs where Open Claw
can just grab a paid image
in my account and place it
in the, I'll just say article.
Uh, it doesn't know exactly.
It doesn't have the context, but let's just see.
Alright, let's see. Short answer,
they do have APIs.
And yes, in principle, open clock could pick images
and drop them into articles,
but they're a big difference between free search
and spending your pay credits.
Unsplash has a public photo, API that has an,
okay, let's go do this.
Hold on a second. Uh, what, what does deposit photo have?
So Unsplash is one, we use deposit,
photo deposit photos offers an API program
with an API key plus session credentials.
The API lets you search retrieve media details.
Nexus purchase licenses. Okay, let's do this guys.
That's awesome. So, uh, we use deposit photo a lot.
Uh, let's go ahead and go in there. Okay?
So let me see if I can log in and get that key.
Uh, it's been a while since I've been in here,
but
am I logged in?
Okay, so is this the,
okay, there's, is this the right account?
Pne? I don't even know. I,
okay, so
how do I get the deposit
photo API key
to get a deposit photo, API,
you have to enroll in their API program.
It's not just to, on a regular create longing deposit,
sign up for the API program, go to the API program page
and click, uh, sign up for the API.
Okay, uh, deposit,
photo sign up for the API deposit photo is super,
super cheap guys.
And they always have like deals and stuff.
I think we pay like, uh, $30 a month
and we get so many credits.
Um,
uh, sign up when I'm clicking it,
it ain't doing nothing.
Uh, API
documentation timestamp.
This API key, okay?
Uh, I might send them a message,
but I'll tell you, uh, what I'm thinking.
If I can get this to work. This might be an old,
lemme try something else.
google.com deposit. Photo API key.
Okay, hold on a second.
Um, to obtain a deposit,
you must sign up for the API program.
Contact their support team
or manager to request access, sign up for the program.
Yeah, that's that same site,
but it's not opening that form.
Uh, the other one. Okay, let's try this. unsplash.com.
We don't have an account here.
Um, but if we did have an account,
um, where is
their developer?
API, the most powerful photo engine in the world?
Welcome to Splash. Okay, register as developer.
Um, I think I have an account,
but what is, I have no idea.
I'll tell, I'll tell you the reason why this is cool.
Um, yeah, well, I'll,
I'll just explain, um,
what we can do here, guys, so it makes sense.
Okay? If you look at iStock, photo, deposit, photo,
Unsplash, any of those, um, uh, services where,
uh, you can get a subscription, you can get
so many credits, you can get a subscription.
So for instance, you can pay like $25
and get like 50 images a month.
It's probably worth it for us.
Doing the newsletters is definitely worth it, right?
So what it can do, like if you look at the, uh, image
that Sherry posted, that is a free image
that it found on Unsplash.
Okay? So you can probably go and ask your open claw.
Hey, uh, do you know about Unsplash deposit photo,
iStock photo and any other place?
There's one called Pixel or something, I can't remember.
PS right? Any other place, uh,
where we can find free photos, put those in your memory so
that whenever you create an article, I want you
to find the best image for that article,
and I want you to do a free one, okay?
So the free ones are not great.
It might work for what you're doing,
but imagine this, if we go to Unsplash,
and let's say that we're paying $20 a month,
or let's say that we have 5,000 credits, whatever,
we can go get the API key.
We can get the API docs, we should be able
to give the API key and the docs to open claw.
So when it writes your article for you, now it can go into,
um, whatever it is, Unsplash,
and it can look at the paid images, the really,
really high quality images,
and it can go claim that image.
It could probably, it could probably just put a preview
of the image there first for you to approve it,
but it can claim that image
and it can automatically put it into your article.
And now you have a high quality image in your article.
Does that make sense to you guys?
Is, is everybody starting to get this right now? Yeah.
So be thinking this way, right?
I mean the, the, the two things today
that I did not have planned are number one, privacy.com
with the virtual credit cards.
And now with Sherry's help, I just realize, oh wow,
it should be able to access the API
go into our paid accounts or free accounts
and it should be able to find the images for us
to use on our pages, on our articles,
you know, whatever we're doing.
Yeah, makes sense. So really be thinking about that way.
Uh, the first thing I ask myself, is there any risk?
Okay, there to me, there's no risk with privacy.com
and there's no risk with, um, this guy here, okay?
There's no risk with a a photo site. Oh wow.
It went and got three photos instead of one.
Okay, that's fine. I'll live, I'm not gonna live if it goes
and sends a spam email to 70,000 of my people,
that's a different story, right?
So, uh, that's the first thing. Is there any risk? No.
Okay, let me open up Perplexity or chat. GPT.
Hey, I got this paid account, or I got this free account.
I'd like to use it with Open Claw.
It would be great if it could do this. Does it have an API?
Yes it does. Okay.
Can it do what it, what I'm thinking it could do?
Yes it can. Alright, write me a, write me a command
that I can give to Open Claw.
I want to use deposit photo, I want to use Unsplash.
I wanna use iStock.
Write me a prompt or a command so I can give it to Open Claw
and it will always refer to those services.
Do you guys understand this?
How many of you're starting to get this right now?
So whenever I give you one of those commands,
I open up Chad GPT and you see
or perplex it, you always see that I've been working
that command back and forth, back and forth, back and forth.
So I build the command over there
and then I give the command to Open Claw.
Okay? Pier says, this is sweet.
Are you guys getting a lot of value on the call?
I had to kind of, uh, make up for it.
Invalid authentication.
Hey, uh, pne, what did we find out on?
Um, she on on Sherry's. Did we screw it up?
Uh, yeah, I'm fixing it.
How big of a fix is this?
Is it a big fix like g just had to do?
Uh, yeah, we do change the configuration.
Okay, so maybe we were not completely a hundred percent
confident to give that out today.
Should I tell people to hold off?
Yeah. Um, 'cause Chris just got a 4 0 4
or a 4 0 1 error too.
Is that the same error G?
Yeah, that could be. And I'm checking why this problem
occurred because they had two end points, right?
One is Sinese, one is ai.
Maybe that's the reason. So I'm checking that.
Okay? So when you get share repair,
can you get Chris Repair two?
Uh, pne. Alright, well guys,
we kind of knew that could happen.
That's the reason why I kept holding, holding it off, right?
But, uh, we have Kimie now running on, um, telegram,
right G So I'm gonna do four slash
model and let's see what we got.
All right, so we're on kimie 2.5.
Is everybody seeing this right now?
So I guess hold off from installing that.
We'll see if we have a new command
by the time we end this call.
We'll test it again, but just hold off for now. Okay?
And, and by the way, you'll see people posting
on Facebook all the time.
I installed this free model and it's so great.
I installed this, I installed that. Guys, you'll break it.
You're seeing it now, right?
These people aren't actually doing this stuff.
They're just seeing somebody posting something
and then they're reposting it and then they're reposting it.
I think we're the only ones that are actually doing this.
I made my Pacino post the other day
and I posted in a group where there was 9,000 people trying
to use Open Claw and I said, here's everything that we did.
And you know what they did? They called me a liar.
They said, you're not actually doing these things.
And I was like, well, I ain't gonna try to dispute that.
Everybody's entitled to their opinion,
but they don't even believe
that we're actually doing this stuff, right?
So don't, don't, don't buy everything
that those influencers,
those gurus are telling you on their wall.
They're not doing it. It's not as easy as that.
It's not as easy as just saying, go install Kimmy 2.5.
As you guys saw today, and we've been working this
and testing it, and still I was hesitant,
but I'm like, okay, we're on day nine.
I gotta get 'em on this cheaper model. Okay? So here we go.
I'm gonna go ahead and take the GC API docs.
Uh, we're gonna have fun with that for a minute. Okay?
Hold on a second. Let me see if I can find it.
Where is it at
GC API Docs.
Hold on. We post it in the chat here.
Okay, here it is. So here's the docs.
And for this one, uh,
I'm gonna do a, uh,
let me try to do a new one.
Okay? So can somebody give me the,
I'm a little disorganized today.
Ashley, can somebody give me the, um, doc
that has the commands I've been giving you?
I'm gonna do this by the book for you guys.
Can somebody give that to me?
I'm sorry. I woke up to two unexpected calls this morning.
And usually, uh, that's my chance, okay?
To prepare for these calls.
Um, but the one that I want
is not this guy.
I want this one. Okay?
So I'm gonna go ahead and take this here
and I'm gonna go into Chad, GBT
and I'm gonna grab a global control
doc, okay?
And I'm gonna run it and let's see what it does.
Okay?
All right, so pace this into open Claw
as your universal API
and jest prompt for global API docs, okay?
On a scale of one outta 10, is everybody understanding this?
So if I was to get the API doc from, uh,
un from deposit, photo from Unsplash, from privacy.com,
okay, I would do the same exact thing.
Does that make sense? This is going to create the command
that we can now go and give to Open Claw,
and it's just a very, very deep digest of
what it should be understanding about those docs.
And I have a feeling that if I ran this through like
Claude 4.6
or something, it would probably be even more thorough
because it's just that model's not gonna miss anything.
Okay? So here's a skill wrapper.
This is the one that I really want to have, okay?
So it's doing all this cool
stuff, all right?
If you want, I can also generate, okay, that's good enough.
That thing is huge.
Okay, so now I'm gonna go
and I'm going to feed this big thing
to open cloth
and I'm just gonna put it inside a telegram
and you can see it's typing up at the top.
Okay?
By the way, Connie is like, you should probably explain
to people that you don't actually have girls talking to you.
And I'm like, I have not opened up Telegram in
for like five years since I've done this.
It's all spam. Like I'm sure they understand that.
She's like, well, you should probably point
that out that you don't want them thinking.
I'm like, okay. So guys, it's spam. Okay?
All right. So let's see. It's still typing.
So what it's doing right now is it's learning the GC
docs, okay?
Uh, where do you get the API doc from privacy.com
or unsplash.com?
Do we ask Chad GPT? Um, yeah, it's a good question.
So, uh,
where can I get the API doc
for privacy.com?
Even though it's the scope is very, very limited,
what you want it to do, uh, a lot of times you,
you can find API docs just by searching Google
or whatever, right?
But there you go. So there's two.
Here's getting started and here is the, um, uh,
part about the virtual cards.
Okay? So just, just ask, just ask Google whatever.
Where can I find the API docs for it, right?
Uh, most of the time it'll be able to tell you.
Okay, so let's see, it's still going.
Now remember, this is Kimmy 2.5 guys,
how do you feel about IT training on
this G are you pretty confident?
Yeah, we just gonna troubleshoot a few things
and then we'll provide the new prompt.
What I'm saying is right now it is training
GC using Kimmy
2.50.
Yeah, I think it would work fine. It should be good
If it does, guys, and that was the question.
Can you train it with Kimmy 2.5?
Well, it's gonna be 85% less cost. Make sense?
So this is definitely one we'll find out if it's okay
to train on this, but this is definitely one
that you probably do wanna run on a day-to-day basis
to do your actions and stuff.
And it'll keep getting cheaper and cheaper
and cheaper and cheaper.
There are some free ones out there
that we will definitely break if we tell you what they are.
So I don't wanna, I don't wanna do that,
but those free ones, guys, trust me,
in the future you will run your software for free.
I a hundred percent guarantee you once it's trained,
your software will run for free.
Those free models will be out there.
Now, they won't be able to do browser control and stuff.
Too many tokens are spent that way,
but they will be able
to pop into APIs from the backend or whatever else.
Um, and yeah, it'll be free.
All right, so on it, reading the G-C-A-P-I docs,
hold on a second, what did you just do?
All right, hold on a minute. Let me see what we did up here.
Uh, I don't, I don't want, I just wanna scroll up.
Can I just scroll up? Okay.
Reading the G-C-A-P-I docs,
let me continue reading the full doc,
continue reading the sections, got all the data.
Now building the comprehensive API map. Here's a summary.
User one, integrations, three broadcast emails,
four contacts, five sub users, five tags, five tag groups,
five tag labels, four custom fields,
four custom field groups, five domains,
five authentication pass, uh,
document envelope, whatever the hell that means.
Parse roll, whatever, sensitive fields, whatever, whatever,
whatever, whatever output file
51 endpoints fully documented with methods, path requests,
bodies, response schema,
status codes ready for skill wrapper.
What the heck does all
that mean, right guys?
Like what the heck does all that mean? Right? So let's see.
Now remember, this is Kimmy 2.5.
All right, let's see.
All right.
So to me, the way it trained,
it identified those, uh, end points.
I, I don't really see. Yeah, we've added a lot of endpoints.
We'll keep adding end points guys,
but I don't really see a big difference, um,
from Opus 4.6 versus what this is doing.
I really truly don't. Right?
And if it's 85% less cost, hey, I'm game. I'm game.
That means when we were at 800, um,
yeah, 80, 85% of 800,
it would've been like less than a hundred dollars
to do everything that we did, right?
Which Is pretty crazy 'cause we win all in.
Like, I don't know anybody.
Um, did we break it?
Are you there?
I think I broke it, G.
Okay, lemme check
51 end points. Okay,
so now that it knows the end points, as soon
as G gets connected again, uh, we're gonna go ahead
and ask it to pull up a contact.
We're gonna see can it access contacts, can it create tags?
And then we'll go into, can you write an email?
If I tell you the tag, can you go ahead and send it?
But before you send it, um,
before you send it, can you go ahead
and send me a test?
Uh, it came back to you. Did you have to do anything?
No, it was working Now,
writing past eight, the open clause skill wrapper plan
done, created both files.
Okay? It was definitely working on some stuff guys.
Test commands, okay?
It's still typing ready
for skill I implementation.
When you want to proceed, uh,
still typing.
And remember when we train it
and give you the skill, you guys don't have to do this,
you can just take the MD file and load it in there.
But I want you guys, uh, I, I want you guys to know
how to train your open claw on um, APIs
because I think that's the most important part of all this.
Alright, final output, verified endpoint inventory.
Okay? Whatever, whatever, whatever,
whatever, whatever, whatever.
Sorry, got way too deep in the weeds there, you think.
Alright, plain English,
I just created a complete cheat sheet
for the global control API,
so I can use it without properly guessing
or properly without guessing.
What I now know the exact URL, how
to authenticate users, all 51 things I can do.
Create contacts and emails, manage tags,
what the response looks like so I can parse 'em correctly.
How to handle errors and rate limits.
Before this, I was piecing it together from tools
and guessing, now I have a full map.
Every endpoint, every field, every quirk documented.
What's next? When you want me to do the GC stuff,
send broadcast, manage contacts, I'll be reliable
because I actually know the API now instead of fumbling
around, do you want me
to turn this into an actual skill so it's even smoother?
Or was it just for documentation?
All right, turn it into a skill.
Are you guys impressed? This is Kimmy 2.5. Is it good?
Uh, candy, put your hand up, we'll fix you.
Oh, you do have your hand up. Nevermind.
All right, let's turn it into a skill.
Still typing.
And you guys notice, I don't even know half
the stuff up there either.
I don't care. It doesn't matter.
It just needs to be the instructor
and learn what it needs to learn, right?
But what I did learn from this
is it doesn't necessarily have to do this.
It still could be running in the background, right?
What does training open claw and APIs mean?
Yeah, it studies your API doc, it analyzes it,
it tests its understanding of it.
Uh, and then once it has that,
we're gonna turn it into a skill called global control.
Okay? So we would do the same thing for Unsplash guys.
We would get the docs, we would create an API key.
We would run it through this
and then we would say, okay, create a skill for deposit,
photo, create a skill for Unsplash.
And now that it has the skill, it can do the 51 things
that it's talking here.
Now, just because it can do those things doesn't mean
that we don't train it
to do other things like tie in Vimeo into it
or tying Sprout into it or, right.
So now we can go training on processes.
So it says on it,
creating global control skill already exists.
Let me update good foundation updating
with the complete 51 endpoint map and cleaner structure.
Done global con, global control skill update
and packaged 51 endpoints.
Guys, the skill now has all 51 endpoints mapped your domain,
configure baked in safety rules for destructive actions,
broadcast email templates, rating limit handling guidance.
Want me to install it in the gateway config so it's active?
Uh, what the heck does that mean, G
I've never seen it asked that question before.
Do you see it?
Yeah. What does that mean?
Um, it's just saying that, uh,
it is gonna detect the skill, but it'll do automatically.
It's just asking you in, uh, like detail.
You don't have to worry about that. Where
It says you Can just say yes,
do yes do it, or something
Where it says install it in the gateway config.
Yeah. Okay.
So what that does is usually when you get skills from
outside, you install it on gateway config, right?
It would automatically do it.
But in our case, we are making the custom one
and we already have the API key.
That's why it's asking.
Did they show Uh, the one at nine?
No, but I have a one of 'em moved for,
Okay, I already active the skills live in your workspace,
it's auto loaded skills, status, location,
endpoint status live.
I can see in my available skills right now.
Next time you say GC or global control
or broadcast email, I'll use it.
Want me to try? Sure. List tags.
All right, let's see if it can go into global control right
now and retrieve our tags.
And by the way guys, we will give you this file.
So we've given you the file for Sprout,
we've given you the file for Letterman.
Now we're gonna give you guys the file for gc.
And what those files are gonna do is they give you the base
where you guys don't have to do all this stuff.
And just because you have the base doesn't mean
that you can't start training it different.
Does everybody understand that GC key is expired?
That was flagged in my health checks.
The key needs refreshing.
I think what happened g,
is we probably replaced the API key, right?
Uh, it could be,
Can you check it real quick so I can use it?
Okay, We probably showed the API key
on the screen guys and we probably replaced it
or regenerated it, right?
Okay. Um,
and it's saying, do you want me to try
to grab via the browser?
If you attach a tab, uh, here's
what I have planned.
I'm hoping tomorrow, um, that I'm gonna be able to show you
how to do this with quiz forma, right?
So we went over Letterman course Sprout, um,
uh, page route, mint bird,
and now we're going over, uh, gc, which is a big one.
So with GC, I should be able to type in the name
of a contact and it'll tell me all the
details about that contact.
Okay? Those are called endpoints.
Next, I should be able to list out my tags, my tag groups.
Um, I should be able to say, Hey, uh,
add al pacino@gmail.com and fire off this tag.
And if you understand the power of our tags, wow,
that's pretty crazy, right?
Um, I should be able to have it write an email
and then it'll go into the email
and I'll say, okay, send it to the actives
or send it to the tag called Open claw
and it'll say, okay, I'm gonna send it to 700 contacts.
Is that correct? Yes. But send me a test first. Okay? Boom.
There's a test waiting in your email.
Yeah, okay, it looks good.
Make sure you put this link in there.
Boom, go ahead, send it.
And then from there, and I don't know if I'm gonna show you
this today, I'm gonna test it a little bit more.
Uh, I should be able to say, Hey, we got a webinar coming up
for the newsletter this weekend.
I want you to write four emails and create the workflow
and here's your link.
And it'll go in there and write those four emails,
set up the configuration, set up the domain name,
set up all that stuff for you.
So now it's created the lead step,
it's created the bridge page, it fires off the tag,
the tag triggers the, uh, workflow.
And now like, do you guys understand this?
Let me know when you're ready g.
Instead, it even knows that it stopped working two days ago.
Soon we'll be able to do a broadcast just asking open claw.
No, not soon. I've already done it guys.
I've already done it for gc.
Would I be able to import a big list of 8,000 contacts
and have open cloth, split that up into smaller, uh, list
to mail a ma?
Yes, you can. You can.
Absolutely. The one thing I didn't get into,
because not very many people are doing it except smart
people, is like what we did with Course Sprout,
where we have the separate pricing options
and we use that to reengage every day.
Uh, right now I have, um, a VA that's doing
that manually open clause should be able
to go in there every single hour
and send out the next, uh, announcement.
It should be able to send out the next, uh, reminder email.
So you're constantly reengaging.
So it can constantly reengage from, um, uh,
gc it can constantly reengage from uh, course route.
Okay? So let me see if I can go inside of here for a minute.
And I want to show you guys,
and to be honest with you, uh, I'm gonna hold on a minute.
Let me bring on the developer so he can hear
what it is I want to have happen
because our system's a little unique guys.
So if I were to come into my contacts, you can see
that I got 9,699 openers.
2023 clickers. Usually I have 300 clickers guys.
It's because of our re-engagement.
419 are active, 11,000 are passive, 47 are new.
2007 45 are undeliverable.
And right now I got 11,000 that I'm trying
to re-engage, okay?
Is, is everybody starting
to understand what's on the screen here?
Now what needs to happen?
And let me make sure I have the developer on the call,
which I do when you, uh, open clock
and put your subject line here, put your preview here
and it can write your email very, very easily.
We've already done that. Now our stuff is a little bit more
different than everybody else.
Now, right now if I choose activity
and if I say for the last 30 days
I have 9,699 people that are active openers,
but what we're building right now is, that's too many
for me just to mail.
What I wanna do is mail the 2000 clickers.
So we're gonna put a radio button here.
When you choose activity that says either openers
or clickers, on a scale of one outta 10,
is everybody understanding this right now?
So now I'm only gonna mail the 2000 clickers.
If I do that, I'm gonna have like an 80% open rate
and like a 40% click through rate.
'cause those are people that are already clicking.
Those are people engaged. Okay? Okay.
So now you gotta think about it.
Everything that we can do here where it chooses openers,
it chooses clickers.
Open claw is gonna ask me.
The first thing is gonna say, okay,
I wrote your email, Chad.
Now do you wanna mail to your actives
or do you wanna mail to tags?
I'm gonna say, let's mail to actives. Next.
It's gonna say, do you want to mail to your openers
or do you wanna mail to your clickers?
And I'm gonna say, well how many openers do I have?
You have 10,000 openers.
Okay, so at this point
or 9,699, I could say to open claw, Nope, you know what?
Let's mail to 5,000 openers and it can do it.
Okay? Or I can go ahead
and say, yep, let's mail to all the openers.
Let, I could go ahead and say, no, you know what?
Let's just mail to the clickers. How many is there?
There's 2000 clickers. Perfect.
Let's mail to the 2000 clickers.
Now you ready for this guys?
And I'm gonna ask you guys again, on a scale of one to 10,
how well do you understand this?
It's then gonna say, do you want me to add extra conditions?
And I'm gonna say, sure, what are we looking at?
And it's gonna say, well, I recommend that you bring in 10%
of your extra conditions.
So 10% of 9,699 is gonna be
969 people.
And so it's gonna say, well,
we have 969 people to choose from.
I'm gonna say, okay, perfect. And it's gonna say,
so if I look at our inactives, we have 419
and for our passive we have
11,000.
And for new contacts we
have two.
Okay? And for dead, we're gonna have a lot.
So let's go ahead
and it's gonna say, you ready for this guys?
It's gonna say, it's gonna give you this summary right here.
So it's gonna know that you want to engage,
you wanna reengage about 10 to 15% of your contacts.
Okay? So down here it is gonna give you a summary that says,
I am mailing 9,699 openers.
I've included a 10% re-engagement,
which is 419 inactive, 500 passive,
two new ones for a total of 10,620.
Scale of one outta 10.
How many of you're getting this right now?
One out of 10. How many
of you're getting this right now, guys?
I'm telling you right now this is fire.
So Pierce says, isn't that too much?
No, because these are actives. These are actives. Okay?
So these are super, super active people
and what we're doing is we are sprinkling 10% of people
that are not active.
Well, so you can do this manually,
but now I'm trying to tell you, hey,
open claw, write me an email.
Perfect. Do you want it to go to actives or tags?
Let's do actives. Do you want me to do extra conditions?
Sure. What are we looking at?
Well, Chad, you can pull another uh, thousand people.
Alright, what do we got? And it'll know.
The first thing is to pull all the inactives
because they were green, they went to red.
Let's get 'em back to green. Next.
Go ahead and pull the new ones.
Alright Chad, we've hit our limit. Perfect.
Here's your summary. Whammo.
Uh, I've gone and I have set up, uh, Chad nice.com.
The from is Chad nicely.
The, uh, email is gonna be support
or it'll be chad@mg.chadnice.com.
And the reply to is support@chadi.com.
So I can just say, okay, use
that every single time as a default.
So then it's gonna say, okay, I've got the default, uh,
sending, uh, broadcast domain set up.
Perfect. Send me a test, it sends me a test.
I open up the email. Yep, looks good. Yep. Send it.
And now it's gonna send to all of this.
How many of you're getting this right now?
So not only are you gonna have it write the email
and it's gonna send out the broadcast,
but at the same exact time it's going to reengage.
You're inactive, you're new, you're passive,
you're dead contacts.
And so if you understand red light, green light,
if you understand everything that I've been telling you
with our email system,
and the reason why Karthik is jumping off
of all the autoresponders and just going to this is
because it's a re-engagement system.
But now open clock and handle the reengagement for you.
Does that make sense to everybody?
So let's come back over here.
Now, now that you've seen that, are we fixed over here?
Gee, I can't remember what we were doing.
Oh, API key. Did you get that fixed?
Yeah, I'm checking that, uh, with, uh, developer.
Okay, can you see it now?
Let's see. All right,
so we're just waiting to see what's up
with the API key That expired on Friday.
Yeah, it expired on Valentine's Day.
That was my Valentine's gift. Okay, still 4 0 1.
Did you generate a new token?
All right, if you guys can kind of hurry on that
'cause I'm outta things to say here.
Um, so what we'll do, guys, the test will do is, number one,
can it see the tags?
If, if it can see the tags, great.
Number two, uh, if I tell you to go look at, uh,
Connie Wiba, can you see everything?
It's gonna gimme a contact history. Perfect.
So that means you can search for any contact.
Next, if I give a new contact
and I fire off a tag, can you do that successfully?
Next, can we go and do an existing contact
and fire off a tag?
It can give you a tag history,
it can give you an email history.
Uh, and then the final one will be go ahead
and write me an email.
Okay? So let's go ahead and do that right now.
Can you write me an email?
Let's just do something crazy, guys. Okay?
Let's do something absolutely insane.
So I'm gonna come over here to munch eye.com
and I'm just gonna look at something here.
Okay? I, I'm, I, I don't even know what this is,
but, uh, let's see.
JV doc, let's try this.
All right, so let's see what happens.
Uh, I want to promote
this product next week.
Can you grab the swipes and find me
and, uh, write me an email
to get people excited for this?
All right, so I just went
and grabbed a Google Doc off some freaking JV page.
That's how this works. Okay?
So, uh, it's gonna go through while I'm buying,
uh, G some time.
All right? It's gonna go through
and it's gonna write me an email.
Okay? So let's see what it does. And that was Munchie.
That's where we list all the launches. Okay?
And it just went and grabbed the JV doc,
or I gave it a JV doc.
I can probably give it the MunchEye
and say, keep me posted on, uh, anything by Karthik, Ani
or Todd Gross or whoever, right?
And so now it went and it wrote this email. Got it.
Here's an email to build excitement. Subject lines.
Pick one. The influencer game just changed forever.
Email, I've seen a lot of AI tools,
but this one actually made my jaw drop.
It's called iic and it creates AI powered virtual
influencers that look, speak in posts like real people.
No filming yourself, no editing, no expensive.
Promote production,
just AI doing the heavy lifting while you
build audience and generate income.
Here's what makes it crazy. Create hyper realistic digital
twins and any niche create viral.
Uh, okay, perfect, perfect, perfect. Think about it.
Da da da. Stay tuned.
All right, make it shorter now, guys, in the future.
Uh, hold on a second.
See, this is, this is how we want our wheels turning here.
Okay? So I'm gonna come back over here
and I'm gonna come back into perplexity.
Uh, does JB Zoo have an API
JB Zoo has it documented for access
and data lake transactions, products, affiliates.
You generate API key, um, can,
it can, uh, open claw
access, uh, JVZ
and get my affiliate link for products.
I'm a, for products I want to promote.
Yes, open Claw could pull your JVZoo affiliate links,
but only if you give it proper access.
JV Z has an API
that exposes affiliate related transactions products
behind an API, key tools like Zapier
and Pipe Dream Connect to JVZoo using that API key.
Then it can read your approved products
and use your affiliate links and automations.
Um, can it
request approval?
There's no public evidence.
J-V-Z-A-P-I unless you submit affiliate approval
requests on your behalf.
Approval is handled through JVZI interface. Okay?
That's fine. So essentially, guys, uh, this is
what we should be able to do.
I don't have that a PII don't wanna log into JV Zoo
to get it right now, but I could,
I'll probably do it by the next call.
So I'm gonna say, uh, let's say that, uh,
my, okay, I'm gonna say this.
My JV Zoo affiliate link is,
um, I, I know nothing about this product, guys.
I'm not promoting it or anything.
I'm just giving an example. Um, we're gonna do like this,
I-M-I-M-I-C, okay?
Is, uh, IMI
c.com.
Question mark T ID equals see nicely, okay?
Uh, always
create an affiliate link or always create a pop link
or any affiliate, uh, link using
Chad nice.com.
I'll let you come up with the slug.
Uh, keep it simple.
Understand, all right? Type it all in URL.
Let's see if it catches it.
All right, let's see if it catches it.
How many of you're understanding what I'm doing right now?
I'm training it. I'm training it to, uh, go into JV Zoo,
grab my link, take it, make it a pop link,
and then put it inside the email,
and then send out the email.
My God, I can't even believe the stuff
that I'm saying right now.
Like I, I didn't think it would happen in my lifetime.
It's pretty crazy. Okay, so let's see what it does here.
Boom. Okay,
so Chad nice.com/i am, I am iic.
I'll create a pop link, simple slug, use
that in email promos, uh, anytime
I, anytime we have an affiliate link
or a link that goes in email, okay?
So, uh, it could be a webinar, join link
training, et cetera, promotion.
As long as we don't have an evergreen
pop link that we use, you always need
to create that pop link.
Understand
a hundred percent understood rule, any link, go in an email,
affiliate links, webinar, join
links, training links, promotions.
Always create a pop link on Chad ison.com,
unless the evergreen pop link already exist.
All right? So I'll give it a link of Evergreen pop links.
Okay? Does everybody understand what we just did?
Um, do me a favor,
create a directory, um, for promotions
we can possibly, uh, do
to schedule out.
Um, and, uh, where, where did it go?
Where did that damn mu I thing go?
And I'm just gonna say, um,
uh, yeah, okay, so, we'll, I'm,
I'm actually not gonna do this, but ab hi.
Okay. All right.
So let's do this,
um, add,
uh, Abby
on, um, uh,
April 28th, 2026.
All right. So I, I could just be like, Hey, uh,
let's go ahead and put, um, uh, this AI repeaters thing
for April 28th, 2026.
Add that to memory. See there, boom. Done.
So as many banks as you guys want to create.
Does that make sense? As many banks as you want
to create, you can do it.
You can do it. If, if I wanted to,
like I was thinking this morning, I need
to go create an Airtable, uh, oh, hold on a second.
See, the more I hear myself talk,
does Airtable have an API we can use
with open claw to go both ways?
You can read from Airtable, you can write to Airtable.
Oh, man. So I can plug in my API key,
and what I can do is I can say, Hey, here's a list
of all of my page services that I'm using.
Can you add 'em to the Airtable
and they could do it for you?
Or, uh, it can go into the Airtable where I have all of my,
um, you know, bills or whatever, and it can read those.
Or I can probably just say, Hey, is there any
concerning anything happening at
the Airtable that I'm missing?
You guys see? Okay, so I can create as many banks as I want
to, right?
Uh, so now I've added that in there. How are we looking, g
I'm still taking there.
Alright, so,
um, let's try this.
Dang it.
That promo that we're going to do
above, uh, what, what's it called?
I-M-I-M-I-C, IMIM.
Can you create a bridge
or, um, a lead step for it?
Uh, just do the best you can on copy.
All right, let's see what it does.
That's, that's pretty, that's pretty crappy instructions.
That's something I would've said to one
of my staff members, right?
But let, let's see what it does.
How many of you're starting to get this right now?
All right, let's see what it does.
And by the way, I never, ever type, uh, I, I always do,
uh, voice commands.
Uh, let me create a lead page. Lead page created.
Now let me add a compelling copy.
Done, created lead step for ai, pre-headline.
Finally, an AI that manages your online reputation.
Headline. Discover how local businesses are using AI
to generate five star reviews.
Enter your best email below to see the demo
and get exclusive launch pricing.
Uh, I didn't want the bullets,
but, okay, it is still trying to connect to, uh, gc,
which I appreciate.
Um, I'm gonna tell you guys right now
that the team is working, uh, very extensively
on, uh, improving, uh, this,
this software here where all the templates are now gonna be
created by ai.
And the reason why is, 'cause I do not wanna let go
of this software because it is lightning fast.
It pretty much runs my whole business when it comes
to lead steps and bridge pages.
Um, can you switch the template?
So now, uh, we've gone
and written the email, we've plugged in the bridge page.
Now, what I need to be able to do,
and I don't know if we have the end points yet,
but I'm gonna ask it, can you fire off a tag
for anybody that opts in on that page?
Okay. I, I set it to a sleek dark template. All right?
So let's see how it did reload.
Okay, cool, cool. Are you guys seeing this right now?
Template has back background. I mean, I,
come on, like, seriously.
Come on. All right, so, uh, take the pop link
and, uh, rewrite the email above,
and in the ps uh, place the lead step.
All right? So let's see.
Take the pop link, rewrite the email above,
and in the PS place the lead step.
All right, let's see how it does.
I got the lead step ready for the ps,
but I'm missing contact.
Okay, that's fine. So I'm just gonna come up here
and, uh, whatever it created,
uh, where, where's the email?
Okay, uh, copy.
I, I don't understand the, the whole green thing,
okay, subject.
Okay, let me just, um, copy.
All right, let's see if it picks it up now.
All right.
So what I wanted to do is I wanted to rewrite the email
and I wanted to, uh, plug in
my JBZ link up above, which is the pop link.
And then in the ps, I wanted to put the lead step, okay?
Uh, influencer game has changed forever.
I've seen a lot of tools, but this
one actually made my jaw drop.
It's called this no filming. Da, da da. Launch is here.
Uh, talk soon. PS All right, you guys seeing it?
You always want to have a link
after the third line in an email.
All right, rewrite that.
See now it's learning how to do emails. Okay?
Um, and I imagine, there we go.
There we go. Um,
I imagine, let me think that, are you able to
put an image above the top link?
We might have to do that through the
yes for GC broadcast emails.
I can include an image above the link. Do you have an image?
Uh, grab it from the page.
Is this cool or what?
And remember, I'm on Kimmy 2.5.
Are you guys liking Kimmy 85% less cost?
Are you guys liking it? This is not Opus.
This is Kimmy. All right.
Uh, uh, yeah. Okay, so let me get you the JV page.
Where's that JV page?
I wanna see if it can actually pull, uh, this, this image.
Okay, so let's, let's just give it this guy.
The reason why is
because I faked it to come up
with my affiliate link up here.
And so it tried to go there.
That was not a real link that I gave it, right?
So let's see if it can get it from the JV page
and write the rewrite the email.
And I don't know if it can show the image in Telegram,
but we'll see what it can do.
It does know that it can place the image in GC email
because we built the endpoint to do that.
Still having problems, G.
Yeah, we are trying to celebrate.
Okay, well guys, we're already on 1230.
Uh, I don't wanna go over today.
Um, what you can do is h how many of you, yes or no?
How many of you know how to train gc?
Okay, so, got it. Here's the email with the image.
Yeah, I didn't think it could put the image here,
but it is showing that it grabbed this image, URL,
and it can, uh,
it can put this image.
Yeah, no, it can guys, it can put that into the GC email.
It can put this in the GC email.
Do you guys understand this? So like, if, if I look at, um,
uh, let me, let me show you what I mean.
This is called an endpoint.
So if I go to, uh, it's gonna take a minute.
We got a lot of history being loaded here.
Uh, but if I go to the broadcast history
for this one right here, uh, you're gonna see a broadcast
that I sent out the other night.
You guys might have seen the email.
It was a bridge page, okay?
And, uh, by the way, that bridge page, it was created
by Open Claw when I was in bed
and it wrote the email, it did everything.
Um, but this is it right here.
So look out of 12,000 people it sent to,
that's too many, right?
It delivered 12,000 31, 50 6% of people opened,
6% of people clicked 467 clickers, guys, okay?
But if I come over here,
and if I open this up, you're gonna see
here is the actual email.
And so, see this image right here, it's saying
that it can place that image there.
And so what it just learned to do is it just learned
to write the same way I write.
Are you guys seeing this right now?
Now, normally I have my gold signature down here
and I can give it that.
I can say, okay, always place an image
and it can go grab its own image,
and then it can always put my signature there,
and then it can always put a PS there as well.
And then if we were connected, which unfortunately,
I know G'S under the gun here, uh,
it sucks when you're under pressure.
Uh, but if we were connected, then uh,
it would go right, that email, it would send me a test,
it would go through that whole process of do you wanna send
to actives, do you wanna send to the tag?
Do you want to reengage?
Uh, it would do all of that stuff make sense?
And that is what I plan on showing you guys tomorrow.
Is that fair? I don't wanna keep you guys anymore.
We've been here too long. Um, but is that fair?
And that way we'll get the API fixed.
Uh, what we will do, uh, by the end of the call today, guys,
I won't give you the, the training on gc, we'll do
that tomorrow together,
but we will give you the updated prompt
to install Kimmy 2.5.
Can you guys watch for that in the, uh,
in the WhatsApp room?
We'll give that to you guys today.
Uh, and then also you guys can already have the GC API
doc, okay?
And right behind the G-C-A-A-P-I doc is
gonna be the quiz form doc.
Now, I want you guys to know that we are
redoing everything with cloud code.
We're redoing all the templates for, uh, um, pop links.
So right now, all the colors are hard coded and everything.
Nope. Now API now AI's gonna create all that stuff for you.
Um, we're redoing all the templates for Mint Bird,
where AI is gonna create all those templates.
We're doing all the templates for a quiz format,
all the templates for Letterman.
Um, matter of fact, do you remember, um, let me kind
of show an example real quick.
Uh, we, we plan on knocking these things out here, guys,
but, um, do you remember g
um, I need to go to, can you assist me with this?
I need to go to West Valley Shoutouts four slash archives,
and then I go into here.
And then what was this, what was this gonna be?
G Can you tell me that name again?
Uh, which one are you talking about?
I wanna show the variations
that we're working on. What was the name?
Oh, okay. It's gonna be layouts.
Layouts. This is not done yet, guys,
but we're just kind of showing you, uh,
the different layouts that we're getting ready
to get into with Letterman.
So you go to CBS News, Fox News, all those layouts,
CNN whatever else, uh, you guys are gonna be able
to have different looks for, uh, all of your, um,
Letterman pages and, and everything else.
We'll have that nice big brand, right?
So everything is being redone, um, with ai.
Uh, so you know, Claude's gonna do the work for you.
We're gonna make sure that you guys
look like a million bucks.
Make sense? Uh,
so if the templates are being redone, should I wait to add them?
No, not at all. Not at all.
The backend functionality we love,
it's easy now we're making the front end look incredible.
'cause we know that cloud's, uh,
open claws gonna run your backend for you.
All right, so guys, um, watch the, um, um,
uh, the WhatsApp group.
Sorry for the problems. Uh, we knew we were taking a chance.
We had our fingers crossed, but you can't win 'em all.
But we still found some pretty good things with privacy.com,
with the photo sharing sites, what we can do@jvzoo.com.
Let me just ask you one last question.
How many of you now understand the power of the API?
All the different things you could do with APIs?
Guys, think about it. All the different things.
We showed you how to train it.
We showed you how it can read the docs,
how it can create a skill from that.
Start playing with it.
Just make sure that you are not, uh,
putting yourself in a volatile situation.
Watch out for security, okay?
Make sure it can't screw you over, right?
That's all you have in a box.
So if it breaks, it breaks in the box. Alright?
So we'll keep you guys posted. Thank you. Thank you.
Thank you. Now you know what's going on tomorrow
and uh, I'll talk to you guys tomorrow.
All right, bye everybody.